do you think we're in a computer  simulation wow what a question effective  conclusion that we're very unlikely to  be another simulation but you know there  are ways out of that argument my  individual life very much so like a game  and like a simulation and you need to be  able to play it and play it well if we  are it's within the computer that we  don't understand do you think we're  alone in the cosmos mathematically no i  would i would definitely say we're all  alone  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  our time in the universe is just so  freakin short we have an awesome episode  today  at some point for different kids the  picture becomes clearer as we learn more  and more  [Music]  [Music]  this truly is the other request vehicle  person me this is the physical vehicle  you use to navigate the physical form  the physical world